hello everyone and welcome back to the
gold money asian rapid knockouts it's
wesley so versus magnus cults and this
is round two
and here we have one of those games
that's extremely simple
uh if you are 2800 if you're not then
chances are it's gonna be a little bit
complicated but not for these gentlemen
as you'll see
they make it look so so simple it's it's
just
insane so wesley with the white pieces
now has to bounce back magnus won the
first game and now wesley needs a win to
get back into the match he opens with e4
we have e5 by magnus knight f3 knight to
c6 and now
bishop to c4 we have bishop to c5 and
the wesley does not go for the strongest
move here rather he plays a c3 goes for
the main line of the joko piano
knight to f6 with d3 and the d6 so this
is all
a very very standard stuff we have
castles uh and
h6 now we have rook to e1 castles by
magnus and knight b to d2
all standard uh joko pianissimo uh ideas
we
a6 and now knight to f1 now the bishop
can come to e3
counter this bishop and if black trades
then you can even bring the knight to e3
so bishop back to a7 and now you don't
want it to get in the line of fire when
white starts pushing b for d4 and now
white starts with a4 and here there is
one game uh alexander grisham played
against uh
when yang in 2019 that he was able to
win
uh where ian played knight to e7 but
here we broke the e8 by magnus
and it is now as of move tender we have
a completely new game so let's see how
wesley continues against
this new idea uh we have h3 makes sense
you want to
prevent this bishop from being developed
so deep into the position
now this is covered this is covered but
the bishop to e6 can be played and this
is what was
what magnus plays so bishop to e6 uh
wesley trades here we have captures
captures and
only now b4 by wesley we have queen to
d7 now ready to bring the other rook
into the game
and now queen to see uh c2 preparing
bishop to e3 and then everything will be
nicely developed but magnus now says all
right since uh you haven't prevented me
in any way from pushing b5
uh that's exactly what i'm gonna do so
magnus pushes d5
and bishop to e3 now uh countering
uh carlsen's dark square bishop on a7 we
have bishop captures on e3
knight captures and now knight to e7
the knight is now coming to g6 from
there it can come to f4 and
the knight on f4 will be will be a
monster controlling a lot of these
squares
so c for by wesley and magnus advance is
the pawn to d4
here of course uh you you can't allow
any capture so you either capture or
push d4
it does make sense to push d4 so d4 we
have knight to f5
and now uh you don't want to capture
here if you capture and then yes you've
doubled white spawns but now the rook is
under attack and you're gonna lose this
pawn it's attacked twice
so instead after knight to f5 we have a5
now by black
of course uh challenging the b4 pawn and
the wesley advances at the b5 so he
keeps the position closed
and magnus says all right do you want to
keep the
position on the queen side and the
center closed completely so now if you
don't capture up a sun
at some point i'm gonna play b6 and
that's it uh we're no longer playing on
the queen side or on the
uh or in the center of the board where
the entire game will be shifted over to
the king's side
so wesley goes knight 3 to h4 now
prepares to bring the queen into the
game
uh and knight the g6 by magnus uh and
again
it's a similar idea to what wesley
wanted to do here he wants the
magnus would like to double his g pawn
to kick away this knight from f5
but wesley not interested in that he
plays g3
uh at some point he wants to trade he
wants to bring the rook to f1 and then
finally execute this f4 to
bust open the position here maybe double
rooks and df file and have some sort of
an attack against the black king
so knights the e8 by magnus and now king
the h2
uh we have knights the d6 now attacking
this knight from here
uh and the queen to e2 the queen now
also ready to jump into the game
uh magnus trades a pair of knights
knight captures knight captures and now
queen to e7
uh wesley goes back with the knight
knight f5 attacking the queen and the
knight here
so queen to f6 still not eager to
capture here on f5
we have knight captures on d6 rook
captures and only now rook to f1
now threatening f4 and then he's going
to try and do some damage here and uh
even though g5 looks like a very nice
idea it's
simply uh it's not enough f4 still will
give white a much better position for
example captures captures and captures
yes you win a pawn but only temporarily
just queens you for check you're going
to win the pawn back and you're going to
retain a better position so after rook
to f1 we have rooked the e8
uh by magnus and now comes uh
f4 as planned uh we have queen back to
d8
and now comes queen to h5 so honing in
on that
f7 square so f6 by magnus and
now h4 so what do you play here magnus
goes queen to d7
now comes rook to f2 you want to bring
the other rook into
the attack as well we have queen to f7
offering a queen trade
queen back to f3 by wesley we have e
captures on f4
g captures and f5 now by magnus but now
wesley just continues with e5 and the b
pawn
is being pressured but the queen defends
it so it's not a problem
we rook the g6 and now comes rook to g1
offering a rook trade and here magnus
just straights captures captures
and if you look at this position the
queen set completely blocked the center
completely blocked there's only the g
file to be used for attack
but it doesn't seem that you you will be
able to do something with this however
these are very very strong players and
if there's a chance
it will be done so here we have b6 by
magnus and
now comes rook to g2 magnus says not a
problem just king h7
uh we have h5 now now the rook can come
over
at the g6 so here we have rook the e6 by
magnus
uh and uh there's really no way for
white to infiltrate
you can play some like queen to a8 but
you can always just kick the queen away
by shifting the rook it's not a problem
so here king the f2 by wesley and now
there's only
one good move for magnus here but it's
uh it's an ugly move you don't want to
play so i'm just going to show it to you
here in order to survive this position
and yes this position requires surviving
magnus has to play g5 and now the point
is
uh after a move like f captures on g5
and h
captures on g5 and the rook captures on
g5 yes you've given up a pawn and it
seems like you
you've uh you know ruined your position
a little bit
uh there's rook captures on e5 now
defends the pawn and what do you do here
white will attack with h6 the threat and
rook captures uh
rook the g7 check to win the queen and
of course if king captures
uh then you will have uh you know a
winning game just queen f4 and now you
have all these
discoveries and if you move the kingdom
queen h4 check queen blocks and queen
captures will be checkmate
uh so uh instead after h6 you have to
find this incredible king to h8 and
had magnus found all of these ideas then
yes uh
you can still maybe uh try and play this
um
you know to to to to a draw
uh but he didn't after king to f2 magnus
just repeated uh
with queen to e7 he thought okay maybe
wesley's just playing uh you know moves
with the king so we can just draw this
very quickly
but now wesley says queen h3 he attacks
the f pawn magnus says all right i'm
just going to defend it
and now we have king to e1 so what do
you play here
magnus goes g6 now he wants to open up
the g file
we have h captures on g6 and now rook
captures on g6 but now
uh if you look at the position the
position is now completely lost for
magnus and
for one a very specific reason so feel
free to pause the video here and win the
game for wesley
uh with this uh well sort of a simple
idea but a most powerful one
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
realizing the king and pawn end game is
winning if you realize that
then the move is uh automatic and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's queen to h5
this spins the rook the rook cannot move
otherwise you lose the queen
and if you know that this king and one
end game is winning
then you found queen to h5 which
makes it all the more important for you
to study king and pawn and games
uh so here magnus played rook to f6 but
we're just going to show
uh if you play as something else uh that
white can just trade just uh trade
everything off calpers captures captures
and captures
and now the end game is completely
winning king f2 white has the central
pass pawn
and that's all all white needs black
does have a
an outside pass pawn but here it's not
going to do him all that much because if
you push it
white will just gobble it up you're
going to have to
either take care of this pawn or if you
guard this pawn then you will allow this
pawn to march forward
so here black can simply just wait for
white to bring his king in king to h4
and then let's say h5 but now you start
advancing the pawn and now the king has
to go after this pawn you're going to
capture this pawn he's going to capture
this pawn
now king g5 and you're losing this pawn
of course the king cannot
keep on defending it these squares are
taken away from him king of seven
captures now you're up a pawn
soon you'll be up many pawns and then
it's a very very easy win
so instead after this rook captures on
g6 uh queen to h5 magnus played rook to
f6 he decided to keep the pair of rooks
on the board to try and defend this
but the wasteland just played queen
captures rook captures and king to f2
uh we have rooked the a7 by magnus now
king the g3 and he was again
in this position on mu 46 that magnus
cross and resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
like we said rook g7 is nothing because
if the
uh if the rooks get off the board the
king and opponent game is winning for
white
and if you don't do this let's say you
try some like king g6 you can activate
your king but then just
king h4 with check king f7 you're gonna
attack the pawn
rook e6 only way to defend the pawn and
now rook the g1
white simply wastes a move and now after
black makes any move you're going to
play rook to g6
because either the rook or the king will
have to leave the defense of the g6
square
so let's say king f8 we play rook g6 and
we win
we said that if the rooks get traded off
the position is winning for white
so you'd have to move the rook then this
falls and then
very soon this will fall this pawn will
fall and that's it
so completely unplayable for magnus so
african to g3
he resigned the game and a brilliant
bounce
back for wesley in round two of this uh
quarter-final match against magnus
carlsen
uh so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
david kimura nigel holloway happy
birthday gavin leandra moderson and
happy birthday ccp for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
uh continuing with uh most likely a game
from the other matches there's been a
really interesting one
uh in a match i will not mention now but
in the
probably next video uh so
probably we're gonna do that uh so yeah
once again thank you for watching and
i will see you soon